the White House is rallying to defend
president Trump's embattled pick to lead
the Department of Veterans Affairs
Ronnie Jackson's nomination is
threatened by a series of allegations
including abusive behavior towards staff
excessive drinking on the job and
improperly dispensing medications if
confirmed Ronnie Jackson would oversee
the medical care of nine million
veterans but his Senate confirmation
hearing is now postponed indefinitely
CBS News was the first to report
Jackson's nomination was in jeopardy
because of questionable behavior at
O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill with this
story ed good morning good morning Gail
the president met with Jackson in the
Oval Office where the doctor said he's
eager to tell his side of the story in
public but the Senate has postponed a
confirmation set for today president
says he'll stand by Jackson but in
public seemed to be nudging him in the
other direction I don't want to put a
man through a process like this it's too
ugly and a press conference President
Trump suggested Ronnie Jackson would be
better off with drawing but said his
White House physician has his full
support I really don't think personally
he should do it but it's totally his I
would stand behind him totally his
decision I recommend that everyone on
the plane take a sleep aid at certain
times one of the allegations against
Jackson that he loosely dispensed
medications fact in the White House they
call him the Candyman the top Democrat
on the Senate Veterans Affairs Committee
said Jackson was known to hand out
ambien and provigil the word is is it on
overseas trips in particular that
Admiral would go down the aisle way of
the airplane and say all right who wants
to go to sleep and hand out the
prescriptions in 2012 the Navy also
launched a workplace inquiry and found
low morale following a clash between
Jackson and another naval officer in the
White House medical unit the White House
doubled down defending Jackson by
providing documents saying it was just a
dispute between Jackson and a bitter ex
colleague and that Jackson's record as a
White House physician is impeccable
Jackson who has been the White House
physician for three presidents batted
away questions about his ability to lead
the VA lawmakers are speaking out
against the White House for repeatedly
nominating people they worry can't
withstand congressional scrutiny this
does raise questions about the White
House vetting process now those
documents released by the White House
included a handwritten assessment from
former President Obama who called
Jackson one of his most trusted advisors
relying on the words of the current
president's political opponent a sign
the administration's eager to
resuscitate the nomination Norah all
right add thank you so much great
reporting